así que tenemos la matriz de la matriz b
y nos preguntan está definida debe está
definido el producto desde el producto
debe estar ha definido sí
y dejado esto bastante claro y esta es
la manera en la que pienso hacerlo así
que déjame copiar y pegar esto para
poder hacerlo en mi blog de apuntes
para contestar esta pregunta tengo mi
blog de apuntes aquí déjame pegar la
pregunta justo aquí
así que pensemos en estas dos matrices
pensemos en estas dos matrices primero
tienes la matriz de primero tienes a la
matriz
haré una grande de aquí y tienes tres
filas y tres columnas por lo que es una
matriz de 3
por 3
y luego queremos multiplicar eso por la
matriz de la matriz b
la matriz p es una matriz de 2 x 2
la única manera en la que sabemos
definir la multiplicación de matrices es
si estos dos números de enmedio
son los mismos si el número de columnas
que tiene b es igual al número de filas
que tiene b en este caso claramente no
son iguales por lo que la multiplicación
de matrices no está definida aquí así
que volvamos al ejercicio y digamos no
no debe no está definido hagamos más de
estos ejemplos
así que tenemos una dos por uno puedes
verla como una matriz de dos por uno o
como un vector columna esto es otra
matriz de dos por uno o vector columna
está definida se más b
bueno la suma de matrices está definida
si ambas matrices tienen exactamente las
mismas dimensiones y estas dos matrices
si tienen las mismas dimensiones la
razón de esto es porque en la suma de
matrices solo sumas cada término
correspondiente entonces en la suma aquí
de hecho sería 40 y menos 2 + 0 que va a
hacer lo mismo que la matriz de aquí
arriba pero lo que nos están preguntando
es cierto estas dos son matrices de 2
por 1 por lo que si está definido
hagamos uno más
así que una vez más nos pregunta si está
definido el producto apure aquí tienes
una matriz de 2 por 2 deja copio y pego
esto solo para que podamos entender
mejor de lo que estamos hablando y
volvemos al bloc de apuntes entonces
esta matriz de arriba que está aquí la
matriz a la matriz a es una matriz de 2
por 2 y la matriz y la matriz
vamos a multiplicar por la matriz
que tiene una fila y dos columnas una
fila y dos columnas en este caso una vez
más el número de columnas de la matriz a
es 2 y el número de filas que la matriz
tiene es 1 por lo que esto no estará
definido estos dos números deben de ser
los mismos para que esto esté definido
ahora lo que es interesante si lo haces
al revés si tomas
si tomas por a
si tienes ahora comprobemos si esto
hubiera estado definido la matriz y es
de 1 x 2
una fila por dos columnas y la matriz a
es dos filas por o es una de dos por dos
dos filas y dos columnas por lo que esto
hubiera estado definido la matriz y
tiene dos columnas que es exactamente el
mismo número de filas que tiene la
matriz a esto realmente toca el punto de
que el orden importa cuando multiplicas
matrices pero en esta pregunta está
definida a por e
no lo está entonces podemos comprobar
nuestra respuesta
no lo está